When I first came here, I didn't go out when it was raining.
I thought that if it's raining, I should stay at home...
...because that's what I usually do in Kyrgyzstan...
...because Kyrgyzstan is a very sunny country.
But then I realized that if I stay at home when it's raining,...
...I will not be able to socialize with people at all.
So I started to go out when it's raining.
What I really liked was English breakfast when I first tried it...
...because in my country, in the morning, we don't really eat much.
It's just like, I don't know, sandwiches, like salad and stuff like that.
But when I first tried English breakfast,...
...the whole day, I didn't want to eat anything else.
I was so full and full of energy as well.
To be honest, London is such a multicultural city that I get kind of lost and...
...I don't really see British food that much because I eat so much different food.